Alexander wanted to and succeeded in
conquering the Persian Empire the
greatest Empire that the West had known
uh to date Hannibal wanted to defeat
Rome which he saw as a threat to his own
country of Carthage he failed but in
doing so he had some very glorious
moments and finally there was Julius
Caesar who first conquered Gaul and
became the leading man in the Roman
Empire no one had ever had as much power
as he did for one brief moment before it
all came crashing down one of the things
that occurs to me is these hisor I mean
these people are
Maniacs Baris truss such a pleasure to
have you on the show we sat down at a
table next to each other here at ARC I
said what do you do you said I'm a
historian of ancient civilizations and
Military historian and I was like we
have to get you on the show right now
come on over we drag we dragged you in
here that's why we're here uh we cannot
wait one of your books particularly
really peaked our interest which is
about the great leaders of antiquity
yeah Alexander the Great Caesar Hannibal
Etc let's get into it sure what what
were the themes that sort of bound those
people together was the common threads
that run through their histories their
lives uh and you know why are they such
significant people in the history of the
world yeah I mean they were uh all three
of them were immensely ambitious uh and
um Wanted nothing less than to be great
conquerors uh they belonged to what
Abraham Lincoln would later call the
tribe of the eagle and the tribe of the
eagle is uh like eagles they're
immensely impressive and Powerful but
they're not always nice uh and nobody
would accuse these three guys of being
nice uh they left uh they waited through
Seas of blood uh in their attempt to
conquer uh Alexander wanted to and
succeeded in conquering the Persian
Empire the greatest Empire U that the
West had known uh to date um Hannibal uh
wanted to defeat Rome uh which he saw as
a threat to his own country of Carthage
he failed but in doing so he had some
very glorious moments uh and finally
there was Julius Caesar who first
conquered Gaul uh and changed the face
of History um and then uh saw him saw
himself pitted in a war against the
Roman senate and defeated all of them as
well and became uh the leading man in
the Roman Empire no one had ever had as
much power as he did for one brief
moment before it all came crashing down
that's right and was it really just
about these guys egos or were the
economic and other the pro CES that made
them you know want to be conquerors made
them want to expand their Empires or was
it really just a big dig waving
competition well ego was a very big part
of it but it wasn't just about the ego
in all three cases so Alexander um could
have seen Persia as a threat to Greek
civilization uh and he saw himself as
the Avatar of the Greeks somebody who
was going to spread this civilization
and create a new Empire so there was
that uh he had been a student of no less
a person than Aristotle uh so he had a
sense of grandeur and a sense of mission
Hannibal uh saw himself as on a
defensive uh a defensive mission to
protect his country from Rome but also
and most important for him was Revenge
his father had been defeated by Rome or
rather his father had been the last
carthaginian General standing who had
not been defeated by Rome in an earlier
war and now Hannibal wanted to avenge
his father who had since died um and uh
put the Romans in their place protect
Carthage forever
Caesar like any ambitious Roman wanted
to add to the Empire so there was that
for his country uh he might have seen
Gaul as a threat although it really
hadn't been much of a threat for several
Generations the G that is uh he also was
by the standards of Roman politics a
populist and he wanted to use his wealth
for the good of the Roman people but
make no mistake about it all three of
these men had huge Egos and that was
always a part of what they did do you
think a lot of them believed in their
own sense of the Divine destiny that
they were destined to be rulers of the
world was that partly what drove them as
well yes uh absolutely in the case of
Alexander you know Alexander's mother
was a woman named
Olympus uh who told him that his father
his alleged father Philip II wasn't his
real father he had been uh the product
of a union with a snake who was Zeus uh
and later on he believed that he was
that the was the son of Zeus uh that he
was nothing less than Divine in his
inspiration and many people believe that
as well because how else could he
possibly have conquered this great
Empire Hannibal did not believe he was
divine um but he thought that he had the
Gods on his side before setting off on
his expedition against Rome he left from
southern Spain he went to the Temple of
uh Hercules um who the carthaginians
called melkart which is in what is now
the city of kadis on Spain it's on the
Atlantic Ocean and the thought was that
only Hercules could have dealt with
someplace so terrifying as the Atlantic
because these were Mediterranean folks U
and then when he invaded Italy he made a
big show of the fact that he had
Hercules on his side and the Romans felt
they had to do something with the
Hercules Gap they had to create altars
to Hercules to counter Hannibal Caesar
Caesar of the three was I think the most
skeptical he was a philosopher um I
don't think he had uh the Gods on his
side so much but the Roman senate either
to flatter him or to uh insult him give
him a difficult political position uh
voted to make name him a God to make him
one of the Gods of Rome and I can only
imag imagine Caesar having a somewhat
amused attitude about that I was in Rome
a few years ago and I went to Caesar's
grave in Rome yes and there is an
eternal flame that still Burns for
Caesar and it just blew me away this man
who lived thousands of years ago there
there is still an eternal flame and
people still lay flowers at his grave
amazing I know there's an Italian
scholar who wrote a book about Caesar
called Julius Caesar Caesar the
Democratic dictator um and so there is
this notion that Caesar was a man of
people he wasn't a man of people but
that he represented the people that he
was a populist um there are those who
see him that way and think that he
sincerely uh believed in the cause of
the Roman people there are others who
that say well maybe but he beli believed
in himself above all and he didn't
shrink from starting a Civil War uh to
defend himself in his position and I
don't know about Alexander the Great but
the other two met pretty Grizzly ends
and it seems that when you talk about
these type of great leaders it's like
tragic characters yeah in the great
plays if you think about in in Greek
tragedy yeah they and so what were their
flaws what did they have that eventually
led to to their own demise well I I
think all three of them shared an
inability to know when to stop um and
that's certainly true in the case of
Alexander who after having conquered the
Persian Empire said I'm bored with
governing this is not what I want to do
uh and he was preparing to start a new
war against Arabia uh when he died in
June of the Year 323 uh BCE how did he
die well that is the interesting
question so U the ancient sources say
that he died died of a fever but they
also say maybe it's also possible that
he was poisoned by those around him
because many people had come to
conclusion that Alexander was mad that
he was he had gone insane that only a
lunatic would want to keep fighting this
way he said that after Arabia next was
Carthage and after Carthage he was going
to go after Rome um the guy seemed as if
there was no off button he just wanted
to keep fighting whereas most of his
soldiers said we're rich now we want to
kick back and enjoy life so there is a
minority opinion in the ancient sources
it's not a modern theory that say well
you know he might have been poisoned and
I think there's a real possibility
that's very interesting Barry one thing
that strikes me is we haven't actually
told uh anyone listening or watching
this what these men did sure so uh then
that is entirely our fault not yours so
could we maybe get a a kind of couple of
minutes about each of them what they did
who they were where they started because
not all of these men started with great
power and
so Alexander comes first chronologically
he was born in the year 356 BCE and died
in
323 um he was born to privilege his
father was the king of Macedon Philip II
who is the most consequential King in
this country had ever had he did nothing
less than create a modern State a modern
Innovative Army revolutionary Army and
then conquered all the Greek city states
and began what he thought would be his
life's work to conquer the Persian
Empire he' started the Invasion sent an
advance Force when Philip is
assassinated and young Alexander at the
age of 20 is now the king of Macedon his
enemies both at home and abroad thought
he'd be a pushover uh but they didn't
understand the guy was a military and
political genius and that he was made of
iron can I just interrupt that how does
a man at
20 become a military genius that is a
really good question um he first of all
he had been trained by his father who
was absolutely brilliant brilliant uh
military commander secondly he'd been
trained by Aristotle who was his tutor
third the guy really just was very very
intelligent fourth his mother had
convinced him that he was a God and so
he thought he had this Destiny in fact
there's a theory that his mother's
behind the assassination of his father
Phillip because Philip had moved on to
many other wives and uh he had a wife
who had just given a son given birth to
a son who many thought would be the real
Heir um so but the other thing is
actually and question is really good
good one one of the reasons Alexander
did so well is that he was humble enough
and smart enough to realize he didn't
know everything and so he kept around
some of his father's advisers some of
his father's top generals and he knew
when to listen to them when it's
absolutely necessary after finally
conquering most of the Persian Empire he
has them assassinated he gets rid of
them but he knows he needs them for a
while so he keeps them around why did he
assassinate them because he thought they
they had they had sons who were plotting
against him and that's what he that was
his that's the reason he gave he might
have been right they may have been
plotting against him because uh the
Macedonian nobility um the bouras have
nothing on these people they were
assassinating each other again and again
again that was their that was their
national sport so it's not surprising
okay so how old was Alexander when he
dies how old is he when he dies he's
just before his 30 turns
33 I'm sort of feeling a bit in
fear okay so that's him then Julius
Caesar or Hannibal hanbal Hannibal next
so Hannibal is born in 247 so about a
century later uh and he dies around 183
this is all BC BCE uh Hannibal's also
the son of a great General his father's
name is hamar Barka uh which hamar the
lightning bolt um he's terrific General
he's commanding the carthaginian forces
in Sicily and Rome and Carthage is
fighting this about 25 year long War for
control of Sicily carage Hannibal Hamil
car is never defeated on land but the
Roman Navy defeats the carthaginian Navy
at Sea Carthage has to surrender give up
Sicily and then the Romans um are not
very helpful when carthage's mercenaries
revolt and hoc Carson the fight of his
life to save his country from The
Mercenaries he defeats them then he gets
the idea to go and start a new Empire in
southern Spain which is rich in mineral
resources and uh Warriors who can fight
for Carthage uh and he is fighting there
when he is killed in a skirmish he
brings with him his uh young Sons H
Hannibal is the oldest allegedly when
Hannibal is eight the father makes him
swear on an altar Eternal Vengeance
against Rome so Hannibal grows up uh and
he eventually becomes the leader of the
carthaginian Army in Spain uh the Romans
are getting wind to the fact that
Hannibal is expanding Hannibal attacks a
Roman Ally sort of an ally a semi Ally
and the Romans send an ultimatum to
Hannibal and the carthaginians saying
stop it you know um admit that we are
superior and we'll call the shots and
Hannibal says no way we want war because
he he is truly of all three of them no
one is better at War than Hannibal um
the overused term military genius
applies to few people in the way that it
does to Hannibal and how does he become
a genius because he's young as well when
he becomes he's not as young as
Alexander you know but his father was
the greatest general of his age and his
father raised him to fight uh when his
father dies he doesn't immediately take
over um I think it's his brother-in-law
some other member of the extended family
takes over and then he's assassinated um
so Hannibal has a number of years to
learn The Art of War but as with you
know all things it's part learning and
it's part intuition and it's part
natural talent and ambition so he's got
all of those um also Carthage was a
place where the Greek experts in The Art
of War and Greece had um was really
where the fancy dancers of war came from
um they had taught the carthaginians how
to fight the Romans were more sloggers
um than maneuver Warfare but Hannibal
was an expert at maneuver warfare that's
his thing so he he he goes on this long
march this 900m long march from southern
Spain all the way across the Pyrenees
across the Ron River across the Alps uh
into Northern Italy with his 37 elant
one of the great epics of History how
anbal pulls this off and then he immed
starts wiping the floor with the Romans
because he knows this new way of war
that the Romans have never seen before
you know the Romans are like an American
football team that only has one play
which is to take the ball and run up the
middle um where and Hannibal is is
executing all these fancy plays and he
destroys Roman army after Roman army
after Roman army he has an a strategy
his strategy is to get the allies of
Italy uh to defect from Rome and to join
him how does he do that
um he is a very fast talker so um when
he defeats the Romans and Roman armies
would consist of Roman citizens and
allies uh the Roman citizens become
prisoners and some of them are sold to
Slaves some they're killed the Allies
Hannibal says you guys go home you're
Italians we're here to free Italy Italy
for the Italians we're here to free you
from the Romans remember the Romans are
only a small part of Italy most of Italy
is made up of other peoples pandal is
very successful in the north of Italy
and in the south of Italy getting people
able to rebel against Rome but he's not
successful in the central part of Italy
that's the nut he doesn't know how to
crack and so although he he hands the
Romans one of the two greatest defeats
they would ever have the defeat at the
Battle of canai uh in August of 216 the
Romans refus to surrender and one of the
reasons they refuseed to surrender is
they still have these allies in central
Italy and they provide the Manpower pool
that allows the Romans to fight and
fight and fight and Hannibal has a
problem he's figured out how to win B
attles but he's not figured out how to
win a war what if you do if the enemy
you keep defeating says we're not
surrendering we're going to go on
fighting so a little bit like Hitler's
problem with Britain in World War II
when Hitler says okay beat you time to
surrender and they say no we're not
going to surrender but Britain had
territorial separation Britain's an
island whereas Central Italy isn't no
it's not an island but these are
fortified cities they all have he can't
sack them he can't because Hannibal has
he has a big problem his problem is he
doesn't like sieges he's not good at
them they're boring to him and in a
Siege in Spain he's wounded uh in his
leg um by uh an enemy uh an enemy Arrow
I think he never forgets this he never
puts in the effort to laying Siege to
these cities uh and that's a real
problem wow see he literally lost a war
because he didn't want to do sieges
because he had a bad experience I don't
know if that's true I wouldn't go that
far that's my that's my uh five and dime
psychology but he never does these
sieges he never pulls them off and you
know um after he wins the Battle of
canai one of his uh generals says to him
we've won Hannibal let's march to Rome
the Cavalry can be there in a few days
and the Army will follow afterwards and
the Romans are terrified now we've
killed 50,000 Romans uh out of about
880,000 who fought um they're going to
surrender we're going to win some Trader
will open the gates and hanel says we
can't do that you know um our army is
too exhausted we took casualties as well
by the time we get there the Romans will
be prepared for us and the guy looks at
him and says Hannibal you know how to
win a victory but you don't know what to
do with it and we're told that years
later Hannibal said ah he was right if
only I had figured out then to go
against Rome and what happens from there
we'll be back with our guest in a minute
but first we want to tell you about
Factor we've discovered a fantastic way
to stay on track with your nutritional
goals while saving time if you're in
America and you're looking for dietitian
approv
Chef prepared fresh never frozen meals
to fuel you on jam-packed days then you
need to take a look at factor factor is
America's number one ready to eat meal
delivery service and they'll help you
eat well for breakfast lunch and dinner
with nutritious and flavorful ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door leave the calorie counting to their
dietitians and leave the planning
prepping and clean up to their chefs
while you're out there crushing it
factor and making sure each meal has the
nutrition you need and the flavor you're
looking for choose from over 35
chef-crafted meals every week that
support a healthy lifestyle and meet
your meal preferences whether it's vegan
veggie Protein Plus or wholesome options
there are also calorie conscious options
that don't skimp on Flavor try delicious
dietitian approved calorie smart meals
that are under 550 calories per serving
the food is fresh and the ingredient
quality is on point for example the meat
is from grass-fed or pasture raised
animals and is free of antibiotics
hormones and GMOs it's high quality
stuff and you just have to run a Google
search to see how well Factor comes out
in reviews to try Factor head to factor
meals.com trigger 50 and use code
trigger 50 to get 50% off that's code
trigger 50 at factor meals.com to get
50% off now back to to the
interview so what happens from there is
that Hannibal you know he now gets uh
Rome's most important Ally city called
capua um to defect against Rome uh you
may never have heard of Capia and
there's a good reason for it because
when this war is over the Romans make
sure that you'll never hear about never
hear of of capio but Hannibal has
southern Italy and Northern Italy he
doesn't have Central Italy and the
Romans have finally figured out that the
way to fight Hannibal is not to fight
Hannibal uh they adopt U they they
appointed dictator named uh Fabius
Maximus um and Fabius uh it comes up
with what we now call the Fabian
strategy that is to say a scorched Earth
strategy harass the enemy deny him food
because Hannibal didn't bring food with
him uh but don't actually fight him um
so they're cutting around uh the edges
of Hannibal but Hann they they can't get
him out of Italy they understand that
they're not going to win this war in
Italy they think they originally wanted
invade Carthage but they couldn't do
that because Hannibal was so disastrous
to them in Italy so instead they invade
Spain where Carthage has this really
important Colony that's the heart of its
Empire aside from the North African
Parts um but the carthaginian armies are
too sophisticated and too good for the
Romans unfortunately for Hannibal one of
the reasons the Romans are so successful
is they're really flexible they're
really adaptable they're not like the
Greeks who would say you know we have
our philosophy we have our way of doing
things
and we're not going to change the Romans
say we're Romans you know we're
pragmatists we're going to do what works
so they violate their own Constitution
and they appoint a young man before the
age of 35 to become their General um and
he retrains the Roman army to fight like
Hannibal um and he brings the Roman army
to Spain his name is uh skipio uh
eventually skipio Africanus because he
defeats Carthage and uh the first thing
he does in a shock move is he takes the
the carthaginian C capital in Spain it's
called new Carthage nowadays Kina in
Spain uh and he takes it uh by
surprising The Defenders at a place they
considered uh the wall was that no one
could climb the wall because of the uh
because there was water there be when um
the tide came in I think it's probably
not a tide but there's some um uh
meteorological effect uh he uses the
right moment to attack they're not
prepared for him and he takes the
carthaginian capital in Spain he then
proceeds to defeat the carthaginian
armies in battle because Hannibal's
Brothers although they're very good
they're not up to Hannibal's standard
and so young skipio has conquered
Spain um Hannibal's still in Italy he
had two brothers one of them's killed
one of them survives and the surviving
brother comes to Italy uh bringing an
army you may have had three brothers
sorry don't quite remember anyhow one of
the brothers brings an army to Italy uh
and he's there to relieve Hannibal but
unfortunately for him the Romans have
gotten better and better um and uh they
have a lucky break uh they capture his
plans uh a a courier is carrying his
plans they capture his plans uh and um
they managed to surprise him and they
destroy the army of Hannibal's brother
uh at the Battle of matus uh they kill
him they behead him and a fast rider
goes to Southern Italy where Hannibal
was and tosses the brother's head over
the wall of Hannibal's uh Stockade and
Hannibal realizes this is not going to
end well so
now the Romans this Ro corne skipio
convinces the Roman senate that what we
need to do is invade North Africa they
really don't want to do it they think
it's too risky but um talk about a
member of the tribe of the eagle skipio
really is that so he does invade North
Africa um and uh he forces Hannibal to
leave Italy nothing the Romans have done
up to then would have forced Hannibal to
leave Italy he could have stayed there
for good but this forces him back home
to make a long story short skipio is one
good General but he's also a very good
Diplomat and the carthaginians also
depended on allies as the Romans did
their most important Ally was the
numidians roughly today's algerians and
what they brought to the table was they
were the best uh light armed Horsemen in
the world they are tremendously good uh
fast cavalrymen uh a staunch Ally of
Carthage but skipio manages to talk them
out of it it's a long fascinating story
involving a woman it's a great story but
we could spend the rest of the time
talking about it in any case skipio you
know sets this up for a final battle
against Hannibal and believe it or not
before the battle the two men meet
Hannibal goes to a meeting with skipio
and it's one of the great dramatic
moments in history to have been a fly on
the wall of that tent would have just
been amazing uh to hear the two of them
talk it's one of my favorite moments
would have been of a podcast right yeah
I would have been a hell of a podcast
and do we know what happened to that
meeting at all uh well we know that
skipio um skipio was playing a double
game he was waiting for his nidian
allies to show up and so he was stalling
for time uh and Hannibal played for it
except Hannibal uh fell for it rather
except I think Hannibal I think is
really really intelligent I think
Hannibal understands that his chances of
losing this battle are pretty great and
Hannibal is already thinking to the day
after okay I lose the battle then what
do I want the Romans to come and uh ask
for my head which they might do or do I
want the leading Roman general to think
we're buddies and that he can deal do
business with me afterwards so I think
that's why Hannibal agreed to this
meeting even though he knew he was
probably not going to get anything out
of it so they have the meeting they
start the battle uh Hannibal is doing
brilliant stuff with what he's got left
he doesn't have the great Army he had
before um and he's quite successful but
the numidian Cavalry show up and they
destroy the carthaginian Army and
Hannibal has to flee
um so that is the end of his attempt to
conquer Rome but Hannibal has if we have
time is a little really interesting
afterlife so um his friendship with
skipio really pays off skipio convinces
the Senate to let Hannibal live and to
let Hannibal be essentially the Quasi
dictator of Carthage Carthage is still a
very prosperous City and um um Hannibal
puts Carthage back on its feet to pay
the reparations the other Romans but he
puts it back on his feet too much the
Romans are afraid Carthage is going to
come back again so they drive him out
Hannibal and Exile now goes to what is
nowadays turkey uh to become a military
advisor to um the uh King there a man
named Antiochus uh and Hannibal is uh uh
the strategist of his war against
Rome he fails in the end and ultimately
the Romans Corner poor Hannibal um and
he suicide he has poison in his ring he
takes the poison it's outside of
Istanbul uh today and you can actually
go to the place where hanal committed
suicide but you probably won't because
almost nobody knows where it is I know
this seems like a very specific question
how quickly does this poison work is it
instant do we know I don't know no I I
um we might know but I don't know know
I'm just curious because it's like you
take the if you've been cornered they
better work quick otherwise you're just
going to suffer for a while that's a
really good point yeah well you know the
ancients were experts in Pharmacology uh
and I'm sure Hannibal had access to uh
to an expert we look it up we look up
look it up yeah all right Barry I was
going to ask you something which is
you've described these three men as
Geniuses and of course that seems
entirely accurate why haven't you
described skipio as a genius oh I could
describe skipio as a genius as well but
I believe in in trinities so I
do bar is Catholic then that's
right and so
and that is amazing and now let's move
on to Caesar yes so Caesar what was his
story so Caesar uh unlike any of these
other three isn't raised by a famous
father he comes from the Roman nobility
but it's a family that's a bit down on
its luck he's raised in Rome his mother
aelia Kata was always a very big
influence on his life and she lives
until he's well on advanced in in years
his father dies we think of a stroke
when he's fairly young U but Caesar
is immensely ambitious and like any
ambitious young Roman Noble he goes into
the military that was what they're
expected to do and already at the age of
18 he's a military hero he saves a Roman
soldier's life in the siege of the city
of mlini in on a Greek island uh and he
is given uh um uh um he's given a crown
um he's given a wreath of glory and he's
so important now uh that Roman Senators
have to stand up and when he enters the
room uh which could go to the head of an
18-year-old and kind of pisses off a
bunch of Roman Senators who think who is
this kid Caesar's the guy who's when you
meet him he's always looking over your
shoulder to see who can uh help him
further um he is ambition defined white
hot ambition uh and he wants nothing but
to restore his family's Glory uh and to
rise to the top of the Roman world uh
his uncle by marriage was Marius as in
Marius and saah Marius was a popularis
which I would translate as populist but
some of my fellow Scholars think they
weren't populist but they kind of were
populist uh even though they themselves
were not men of the people they were
very very wealthy but we can see even
nowadays we have populace are not men of
the people um and Caesar in in a period
in which Roman politics was always
divided between um the the men of the
people and the men of the few the
oligarchs and the populace he was always
on the side of the populace um he wanted
to to rise to the highest political
office in Rome uh to become uh the
consul and then to have a military
command which will allow him to win
Glory supposedly when he's in his 30s he
has a relatively minor command in Spain
and he sees a statute of Alexander the
Great and supposedly he starts crying
Alexander was dead uh when when he was
at my age and he'd already conquered the
world what have I done so he's he Caesar
has it all he's a great General he's a
great speaker he is a great political
manipulator and he's also a great writer
I mean he writes great literature the
Galla Wars and the Civil Wars um they're
hard to translate so it's hard to get it
in English uh but they really are quite
something he wrote other works as well
which no longer survive uh and as a Bes
behind the scenes manipulator he creates
a uh a conspiracy uh with two other
leading politicians more prominent than
him crus who's the richest man in Rome
and pompy who's the most successful
General to date they're going to do a
deal Caesar is the guy who can make it
happen he's the dealmaker uh they each
get something Caesar gets to be Consul
pompy gets his
um the steps that he's taken in the East
he gets them approved by the Senate he
gets his men um uh settled on land in
Italy his veterans and crus gets the
command to fight a war against partha uh
Iran basically in the East uh crus fails
and he's killed in battle uh pompy gets
what he wants um but he is Caesar's
son-in-law he's married to Caesar's one
and only legitimate child his daughter
uh but she dies in child birth and cus
is increasingly jealous of Caesar excuse
me pomp is increasingly jealous of
Caesar sorry I'm confused she dies in oh
she dies in child birth as in but she's
not the child sorry I was like he was
married to a baby how's older a few
years older than Caesar sorry I was
being stupid no not at all he marries
Caesar's daughter so he is technically
Caesar's son son-in-law the Romans like
the mafia did these kind of marriages
all the time to seal political deals
right and U in the meantime Caesar gets
what he really wanted command of Gaul to
start a war in Gaul and Conquer All of
Gaul which is basically France and
Belgium and just for good measure he
crosses the Rind and invades Germany and
then he crosses the channel and invades
England which to the Romans was the
equivalent of going to Mars or the moon
wow the Atlantic Ocean the the English
Channel so SC
but he does it pomp is getting more and
more jealous at this guy you know I
thought I was the greatest General in
Rome who's this guy he thinks he the
greatest General so uh when Julia
Caesar's daughter dies in childbirth and
Caesar says don't worry I I got a niece
I'll marry to my niece pompy says I
don't think so and pompy now moves to
the other side in the other faction
after Caesar conquers Gaul he wants to
come back to Rome and have a second SL
as Cil uh be respected as the leading
man in Rome pass some laws that will
help his constituency the poor people of
Rome and settle his veterans but he has
made huge enemies very powerful enemies
anyone in Rome who considers himself a
conservative uh of any sort at this
point thinks that Caesar is a threat uh
to their way of life why ah that is a
good question there's two theories of
Scholars uh one is that they were died
in the wo per blind fools who didn't
understand that Rome needed to change um
they thought they could uh turn the The
Hourglass back and keep Rome the way it
had always been Rome had acquired an
Empire of 50 million people at a minimum
uh but it was governed by a few families
in the city of Rome this was crazy they
had to bring in The Outsiders both pompy
and Caesar knew that but the
old-fashioned Senators didn't there is a
second the and also the oldfashioned
Senators hated the Roman people and they
didn't want to see them get more power
but there's a second theory that says
well that's all well and good but the
truth is that Caesar was an egomaniac
who wanted to dominate Rome as no one
had ever done before I actually think
both theories are right I think that uh
these uh Senators really didn't
understand that Rome needed to change
they didn't like the Roman people but
Caesar was no pussycat uh Caesar wanted
enjoy a kind of the Romans made a
distinction between power and authority
power is legal power is written in Stone
Authority is the informal power and they
called it aoras and there's no doubt in
my mind that Caesar wanted to have the
kind of aoras that would make him the
greatest Mafia dawn of all time uh after
all he settles for nothing less than
Cleopatra as his woman um and she Bears
his son almost certainly Bears his son
they see this they he's not with
Cleopatra yet but they see him as a
threat uh to their way of life and so uh
they demand they fire him and uh say say
step down come back to Rome stand trial
for your crimes and Caesar says I don't
think so I think I'm going to invade
Italy instead and start a Civil War and
he says I'm doing this for two reasons
one is to defend the Roman people
because the the um the tribunes of the
plebs who are in technically Defenders
of the Roman people in the Constitution
uh they have been dissed by the Senate
which is true they had been dissed by
the Senate but the second reason he says
and to me this is vintage Caesar it's
because my rank and standing is greater
to me than my life itself in Latin my
dignitas is greater to me is dearer to
me than life itself and dignitas doesn't
just mean dignity it means my rank my
standing my reputation so for this he
starts a civil war it's a civil war that
rages for four years it ends up seeing
um his opponents pompy being uh murdered
KO committing suicide the other generals
being killed in battle and Caesar
winning it all including Cleopatra he is
now the uh dictator for Life dictator in
perpetuity there's never been anyone
like this in Rome before and it's that's
when a conspiracy of senators decides
noas we've got to stop this guy and do
they say that because he's essentially
resered all the power that there was and
they're like this guy's out of control
yes by now he is really out of control
and even some of his former supporters
say wait a minute we didn't sign up for
this you know we didn't sign up for this
guy behaving like a mafia Dawn and
giving the the choices jobs to his
family members we didn't sign up for
this guy basically abolishing elections
he didn't technically abolish them but
de facto abolished them and the Romans
really cared about election so uh and
they didn't like the idea that he was
dictator in perpetuity what does this
mean uh no one Romans never dictator
suppos to for six months only um and
they didn't like the idea that the
senate had declared him to be a god um
so for all and they didn't like the idea
that his he had a Roman wife but his
mistress who by the way he kept in a
palace across the Tyber Caesar's Palace
we'll call it now Caesar's Villa really
was that's where Cleopatra was at the
time of his assassination hanging out in
Rome um and she was probably pregnant
with his second child but she has a
miscarriage so there are just a lot of
people in Rome who've had it with this
guy that makes sense and Barry it's so
interesting to me because I've never
we've never interview the historian
about these individuals in this way I'm
just this is a brilliant conversation we
so happy to have you fantastic one of
the things that occurs to me is these
great historic I mean these people are
Maniacs in a way yeah Ian I mean if you
had a guy now who came along and was
like look I want to be great therefore
let's go and invade France I mean France
is yeah invade France I've got no
problem invading France but invade some
other country kill loads of people so
that I can raise my status in the
hierarchy of my Society we would say
that guy's a lunatic lock him up but if
but it's not only that that but it is
that but it's not only that but look at
some other modern examples look at
Abraham Lincoln he has a choice he can
make peace with the South and say well
at least nobody died or he can fight the
war however it takes and by the time the
war is over 600,000 people or 600,000
Americans on both side are dead the
south is in Ruins and finally the last
casualty is Lincoln himself some people
might say that's crazy or Churchill you
know Britain could have made peace thank
God they didn't but Church
basically said whatever it takes
whatever it takes you know and if
Britain's going to be in Ruins and a lot
of uh British people die that's what we
have to do to save our way of life and
that's different isn't it that's
different because both Lincoln and
Churchill they're also fighting for an
idea well whereas here it seems much
more about personal EGO power maybe
because I've made it that way okay but
no you're right there is a difference
because but it's also from our point of
view Caesar would have said I am
fighting for the Roman Empire we Romans
believe that we are destined to govern
the world as his successor Augustus says
Empire Without End that comes from
virgils the unot and that's what Romans
thought and Caesar would also have said
the GS have threatened Italy's Security
in the past and that will never happen
again they hadn't threatened Italy's
security for 60 years but never mind
um and also Caesar believed and I'm the
only one who stands up for the common
person in Rome so there's that too but
you're absolutely right in all three of
these cases there's ego Hannibal thinks
he's defending his country and getting
revenge Alexander thinks he's defeating
the Persian threat and making Greece and
Macedon the greatest power in the world
and changing history and spreading
civilization which in fact he did do so
you know it's let me rephrase what I
mean if we found out yeah that Rishi
sunak yeah is or Joe Biden are sitting
in their offices and in in the overal
office and then number 10 Downing Street
yes and they're saying well you know my
mother told me that I
am born of a snake that is God right and
therefore I am entitled to conquer the
world yes we'd get the mental hospital
out there urgently to deal with them how
could imagine Trump saying
that it is
possible which which I think it's fair
to say some people have critic for to
put it mildly do you see what I'm saying
I mean is it fair to say that not only
is it that these men are different but
the culture in which they operate is so
different that we would probably
struggle to relate to it at this point
yes and no yes and no I mean we have
politicians today who might say I really
think I'm here for a reason God put me
here for a reason and my reason is to
help the people the reason is to defend
my country we could imagine a politician
saying that m
so I mean these These are countries with
different religion so well I mean
Vladimir Putin almost certainly thinks
in the sure and I mean there are other
Greeks at the time who couldn't stand
what Alexander said Alexander later in
his life passes decree saying I need to
be worshiped as a God I insist that
everyone worships me as a God and the
various Greek city states you know
couldn't agree fast enough to do this
except Sparta Sparta says if Alexander
wants to be worship as a God let
him I mean the Spartans were they were
pretty badass weren't they they're
pretty badass yeah yeah yeah you've got
to have a really strong sense of
identity to stand up to Alexander the
Great no they they were happy in this
instance they went along with it right
no no no no no sorry I mean you know the
idea if that's what he wants go ahead
they more like go ahead and make my day
sorry sorry sorry they basically gave
him the finger oh I see exactly they're
giving him the finger thank you you put
it you put it so
well so and so we we'll move back to
Cesar in a second so so what actually
happened with with the Spartans when
they gave him the metaphorical finger
nothing nothing happened I mean uh for
one thing Alexander was far away he was
in Iraq uh for another thing nobody
really cared about Sparta that much
anymore and besides which it would have
been bad for business for the
macedonians to have destroyed Sparta
just as it was bad for business for them
to destroy Athens Athens rebelled twice
they didn't destroy it they did destroy
thieves which they could get away with
they get away with because all of
Thieves neighbors hated thieves and
wanted to see it destroyed um at this
point Sparta was no longer a great power
it was um it was on the decline and yet
it had a lot of prestige for what it had
done for the Greek world so they got
away with him and then Alexander died
and his successors had other things to
do like fighting each other so they
didn't wor that much about
Sparta we'll get you back to the
interview in a minute but first we've
got a special message for the gentleman
of our our audience from our sponsors
manscaped look gents Valentine's Day is
a knocking and manscapes all new
performance package 5.0 Ultra has been
meticulously designed to elevate your
grooming game and help you shine like
the heartthrob you are join the 10
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped with our exclusive offer
inside the package you'll get the best
Tremor on the market the lawn mower 5.0
Ultra this this is their fifth
generation trimmer that features two
interchangeable Next Generation skins
safe blade heads there's a standard head
for taking a little off the top that's
what I like and a new foil blade to go
smooth wherever your heart desires bit
adventurous bees to their own also
inside this package you get the weed
whacker 2.0 ear and nose hair trimmer
perfect for the middle-aged men
manscaped cologne a travel bag and
manscape boxes
2.0 which are incredibly comfortable
might I add because I'm wearing them now
and you wouldn't suspect a thing also
for the bearded chaps amongst us
manscaped brings you the beard hedger
Pro kit I wish I could grow a beard
designed to shape your Scruff
effortlessly it sculpts cheek lines and
maintains beard styles giving you that
swaave look ready for you to pull off
your romantic moments here's the offer
get 20% % off plus free shipping with
the code trigger2 at manscape.com that's
20% off plus free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com
manscaped trim your chesticles with the
besticles they made me say that I'm a
professional comedian I'd never write
something like that anyway back to the
interview so moving back to Caesar then
so so we're talking about essentially
the end of Caesar's life yes how how did
the conspiracy arise how did the
plotters get together and how did they
execute it so um the conspirators that
there were three main conspirators two
who we know from Shakespeare Brutus and
cases and there's a third one who
Shakespeare just um um kind of disses
really his name is desus Brutus he's a
distant cousin of Brutus and cases
Brutus and cases had both fought against
Caesar in the Civil War and then um
after being defeated had asked for a
pardon for Caesar and he gave it to them
desus Brutus is different he'd always
fought for Caesar and with Caesar both
in Gaul and then in the Civil War but he
changes his mind part possibly because
of his wife uh who comes from an anti-
Caesar family and partly possibly
because he sees that Caesar is moving on
to new favorites Caesar is planning to
invade Iran that's is going to be his
life's cap his life's work they the
parthan Empire um but he's leaving
Decimus Brutus at home um and so desus
is is pissed off about this Brutus and
cash Brutus is a philosopher he is
married to the uh the daughter of ko the
Elder who is Caesar's most uh vehement
enemy um and Brutus really believes in
the principles of the Roman Republic um
cases is more of a military man less of
a philosopher but they both don't like
the way that Caesar has U uh gained
power and desus has decides to go over
to their side so they gather together a
group of depending on who you believe
either 35 or 60 some odd uh senators or
60 some odd Senators let's say to join
this conspiracy to kill Julius Caesar
and they want to do it um in a way they
want to do it themselves first of all
they could have hired thugs to do it I
want to do it they want to do it
themselves to show that this is not just
a garden variety murder but it's
something for the for the sake of Rome
and they want to do it in a meeting of
the Roman senate again to make the point
we're not killing him out of peak or
ambition we're doing it out of idealism
for the Roman senate they managed to
keep it secret because Caesar doesn't
really believe it it's not as if he
doesn't get rumors of conspiracies
against him the problem is what they
call noise he's getting rumors every
single day of conspiracies against him
and so Caesar also thinks whatever the
other thing is Caesar's very arrogant
we've seen this a lot in history Caesar
thinks who would be crazy enough to kill
me Rome has just gone through a fouryear
Civil War and it was disastrous huge
casualties huge destruction if you kill
me Civil War II the Sequel is going to
break out who would do that I'm
untouchable and we see the result it
brings up an interesting question
branching out Beyond these three figures
specifically barriers you mentioned and
from the way you tell the stories it
seems certainly true that these guys
really didn't know when to stop right as
you they didn't know when to stop they
absolutely didn't know when to stop are
there leaders of their magnitude and
history who did yes um I'll give you a
couple of examples uh one is William the
conquer after conquering England he says
that's nice I think I'm gonna I think
I'm going to administer this place he
didn't go on um so um I suppose the
difference there is he conquered a
kingdom that he he didn't have he wasn't
a king before right but he could have
gone and tried to conquer more kingdoms
that's true so that's true but yes
Alexander conquers the kingdom he didn't
have before
but wasn't he king of a kingdom already
yes right that's the difference but but
uh William was the Duke of Normandy
which is no mean Place yeah it's a big
it's sure it's a it's a big place but
he's no King so that's one and he he
stays and governs yeah anymore uh
Ataturk yes atat you know turkey's ass
satiated power said that's enough we're
don't going to do this anymore don't
need anymore I mean he wasn't a nice guy
um but uh he does know when to stop um
in a sense George Washington sorry my
British friends but Washington could
have become a king and he said no and he
could have been president for more than
two terms and he said no that's that's
enough so is it is is it partly because
these figures come later on in history
therefore they don't have this idea that
they have been ordained or by God or
representing God or even being literally
god um I don't know Napoleon is later
than than uh it's pretty late in history
but doesn't know when to stop say that
again Hitler's pretty recent and he
didn't know when to stop um you know I
think oh another person who knows when
to stop is Franco you know also not a
nice guy but you know Hitler saying to
him hey come on come on don't you want
to join me and melini in the war and he
says I don't think so no no no we have a
lot of we have problems in Spain no I
think we'll be neutral imagine if
musolini had stayed neutral in World War
II he would have survived you know and
Italy would have been spared a lot of
Ruin so
um so there are people who know when to
stop they really are and going back to
the question of fatal flaws was that the
all was that their fatal fla of these
three great men which is the inability
to stop or was there something else as
well oh something else I mean um it's
less true of Hannibal you can make a
case for it than it is of Caesar and
Alexander but they're so arrogant these
they're just so arrogant uh the idea
that um it's related to knowing when to
stop but the idea that they would keep
on going after what they had done or
that Caesar thought that he was
Untouchable or if Alexander really was
poisoned that he didn't see that coming
either um Alexander had actually
murdered one of his leading Generals in
a fit of rage earlier on in his life um
and that certainly impressed some of his
generals with thinking the life
expectancy in this job is not very great
so I mean they made enemies that they
that that they didn't need to make or
for Caesar to think that he was that he
was
Untouchable uh before we uh wrap up
we've only got 10 more minutes or so
before we go to questions from our
locals you're a military historian as
well and one of the things I was
fascinated about when you were talking
about how the Greeks while the Romans
were these kind of sloggers perhaps not
very skill tactically the Greeks came up
with new ways of fighting yes what was
it was it technologically based was it
intellectually based did they come up
with tactics that were powerful what was
it so I mean the Greeks and it's really
the Macedonian Greeks who who come up
with this um they create a comb combined
arms military that uses the Infantry and
the Cavalry working together um and that
is a very very potent combination when
you can do that the Romans are really
not good at that um the macedonians so
Greek armies were pikemen the armies of
the city states and shield and spear
shield and Spear and but they didn't not
a javelin but a pike you know come up
against the enemy and just hit and hit
and hit it was pretty simple um but the
macedonians come up with a a new system
whereby um so the pike of the Greek uh
hop lights was in was 9 ft long the
macedonians come up with a new Pike
that's about 15 feet long uh the pike a
9 foot long Pike you can hold in one
hand while you have a big body shield in
in a you hold through a thong with your
left hand you can't hold a 15t uh spear
in your hand it's too heavy you need
both hands uh so the solution and you
can't have uh a you don't have a handh
hold of body Shield if you put the body
shield and thong around your neck it's
going to choke you so the solution is to
have a little Shield how do you do that
uh well the macedonians are the hardest
drinkers in Greece so they go into
battle uh having had Dutch courage as it
were and a lot of Dutch courage the
other thing is that the Greeks in the
city states are citizens if the generals
have told them you don't have you can't
have so much protection anymore they
would have fired the generals
macedonians are subjects in a kingdom
the King has more power and frankly
they're kind of hillbillies and U
they're willing to take chances because
they want to get rich uh in a way that
Greek citizens weren't uh they trained
year round these were professional
armies the Roman armies weren't
professional armies in the beginning
either uh that gave them an advantage
and it allowed them to maneuver to do
things for instance like feigning a
retreat a very hard thing to do and when
you draw the enemy in faint to retreat
with half your army draw the enemy in
and then turn on around and hit the
enemy on two sides that's the kind of
thing that um these Greek armies could
do and then use the Cavalry to disperse
the enemy and then use the Infantry uh
as the hammer um that's the sort of
thing it's difficult to do Hannibal
could do that brilliantly uh the Romans
couldn't until they learned to uh beat
him at his own game and why couldn't
they do that do you does it take some
kind of signaling or command or training
no not at all it's culture I mean
culture is in many ways the most
important factor for any uh any military
um you know um why do Army National
armies fight in the way they do it's the
culture of the country I mean why do the
Russians think you should just send in
men like Canon fodder and slog and slog
and slog because that's the Russian way
of War I mean it's just that's just the
way that they do it uh why are some
countries very good at cunning uh and uh
Special Operations and others not has
everything to do with culture and just
touching the the culture that's always
really interested me is the culture of
the Spartans yes I just as I remember as
a kid watch 300 yeah I've watched 300
and I've read the
comic but as a child I was obsessed with
ancient Greece and I was particularly
obsessed with Sparta I remember people
going was a bit weird that he just sits
and reads books about Sparta but what
what made them such incredible Warriors
Spartans they were professionals you
know they were professionals they were
the only professional military in Greece
before the macedonians before Philip and
Alexander Sparta was a society was a
pyramid uh at the bottom were the helots
these were the Surfs at the middle were
the neighbors um they could lead
relatively ordinary lies but they had to
serve as Spartan allies when needed and
at the top was a small group of full
Spartan Warriors the so-called peers
9,000 of them at at the population
height they all they did was train for
war
um and they had a bizarre educational
system uh U they were taken from their
parents at the age of seven and they
went to live in ageg graded Barracks um
where they were uh their primary group
was boys of the same age and there they
were taught how to fight uh and they
were also taught how to be tough to uh
live out in the wild to steal to kill to
do what you needed to do to survive so
they had the most professional and
toughest soldiers in Greece um so that
that is uh one of the reason they're so
strong also their entire Society is set
up in a military basis it's an austerity
Society uh ain't no uh none of this
culture stuff the only songs they sing
are military songs the other thing is
the role of the Spartan woman which is a
very big part of it uh women in Sparta
Were Meant To Be wives mothers breeders
and their job was to tell the men to
Buck up uh the famous staying of the
Spartan mother T some when he one goes
off to battle with it or on it come back
with your Shield don't throw it away
like a coward or come back dead on your
Shield I'd rather have you dead than to
have you alive without your Shield um
Spartan uh girls were the only girls in
Greece to have a public
education um they were uh trained to run
the household when the men were away uh
but they also trained in gymnastics and
they were trained in the nude Greek boys
were trained in the nude nothing unusual
about that but only in farter were girls
trained in the nude as well and boys and
girls would see each other in the nude
in public uh the idea was to get
everybody really horny uh so they would
go off and make Future Spartans so uh
it's a whole society that's set up for
war it's really quite remarkable and
horrible it sounds like you know the the
comic uh movie or whatever it is is
actually not that inaccurate in terms of
how they were trained no it's not that
inaccurate it's not that inaccurate yeah
and it's very interesting as well and
particularly brutal the way they treated
boys who weren't going to make it or
they didn't think were well so I mean
the Spartans had this system that when a
baby is born a baby has to be inspected
by a public inspector uh and if they
think the kid is sickly or not going to
make it they expose the child on a
mountain side uh where the baby will
either die or somebody might take him
and enslave the uh enslave the child the
sparta was the only Greek state that did
did this as by government initiative um
but the other Greek States a father had
the authority to do this to his own
child but it'd be much more difficult
for a father to sacrifice his own child
than it would for an impersonal state to
do it and why did they never because if
you look at them militarily and and the
fighters that they
produced they're still famous now
Spartan warriors still even people who
may may understand very little about the
culture that still resonates why is it
they never went on to conquer the world
because you don't win war it's a great
question but you don't win Wars just by
having uh having good soldiers for one
thing the most important thing you need
to have to be successful at war is money
and Spartan didn't have any money
Spartans abolished money uh they had a
barter system and they had U ungainly
iron spits because they thought money
was corrupting corrupting um and that's
the other side of the Spartans they
really didn't want to conquer the world
they wanted to be pure they wanted to be
great pure Warriors so they conquered
the pel anesis the southern peninsula of
Greece and part of Central Greece they
didn't want to go any further the other
problem is that reason is they have a
security problem um All Greek city
states have enslaved labor unfree labor
but Sparta is one of the only ones in
which the unfree laborers are Greeks in
Athens the unfree laborers are all
kidnapped enslaved brought in from
abroad and then um they're bred enslave
families in Sparta they basic most of
the people they've enslaved are their
neighbors to the West the meinian Greek
uh and the Spartans make the mistake of
letting these people to continue to live
in their National Homeland um they want
their country back uh and they rebel
against the Spartans whenever they can
the Spartans young Spartan boys as their
initiation into the military have to
spend two years living in the
countryside where the helots are and
making their lives miserable uh they
have the right to kill them every year
on New Year's Day Sparta declares war on
the hots and say we can kill these
people if if necessary um so um they
have the security problem but they have
this notion of Purity which is not
really what you want if you want to
conquer the world you need to be a
pragmatist and the Spartans are anything
but pragmatic Barry I I mean I I hope we
get a chance to have you back about 50
times because we can talk about the
Romans as an Empire the Greeks there's
so many other things we can talk about
and Carthage is one thing is amazing we
don't know about because the Romans kind
of make short we don't know about it so
uh if you have time at some point we
would love to have you back
Locs we ask question audience been
pleasure of the leaders you have written
about or researched who would be perfect
to lead the West out of the current
situation and whom should today's
leaders
[Music]
emulate